[Musique]
Karachi dans le sud du Pakistan la
mégalopole vibrante abrite de nombreux
artistes avant-gardistes cette nuit-là
c'est dans le plus grand secret qu'un
événement exceptionnel est organisé
un festival de musique qui met en
lumière les minorités
[Musique]
et les artistes transgenres l'événement
a été interdit car accusé de soutenir le
mot sexualité considéré comme un crime
au pays des pures et qui est passible
d'une peine d'emprisonnement
le festival est enregistré dans ce
studio afin d'être diffusé sur Internet
[Musique]
elle est connue pour son humour cache
étrange
nous avons dû faire face à de nombreuses
difficultés pour organiser ce festival
des campagnes de désinformation sur
internet à la décision de la Haute Cour
de justice qu'il a interdit ils ont dit
que ce festival répandrait la vulgarité
ce qui serait contraire aux valeurs de
la société pakistanaise je voudrais donc
envoyer un message en regardant très
sincèrement la caméra à vous les hommes
pakistanais s'il vous plaît tenez vous à
distance de l'homosexualité mais je ne
vous en veux pas en même temps les
saucisses sont délicieuses et vous voyez
d'ailleurs que l'avion est au cœur de
notre gastronomie
cet événement s'est déroulé dans un lieu
secret en raison des risques de sécurité
il devait s'agir d'un événement public
mais la droite religieuse et les
islamophhasistes ont lancé une campagne
de désinformation en affirmant qu'il
s'agissait d'un événement
lgbtqia+ qui encouragé l'homosexualité
cela a signé la mort de l'événement car
il dit ça pour cibler spécifiquement la
communauté des hawajasira
[Musique]
nous sommes des chorégraphes des
danseuses des humoristes et des
maquilleuses des scénaristes l'industrie
du divertissement pakistanais s'est
construite sur les artistes rawage
Assira qui ont été invisibilisés
[Musique]
ce festival est celui des personnes
marginalisées maintenues dans l'ombre
pendant trop longtemps et qui veulent
désormais qu'on les accepte tels
[Musique]
parmi les célébrités présentes alinaran
actrice phare du film Pakistan et
Joyland qui a remporté le prix du jury
au Festival de Cannes cette année un
film dont la projection a été interdite
dans la majeure partie du Pakistan
j'ai commencé à être accepté par la
société après le film Joyland alors que
j'avais du talent avant je me produisais
dans la rue où je n'étais pas respecté
la stigmatisation des personnes trans
comme étant des mendiantes des danseuses
est le fruit de la société la seule
solution et qu'elle nous accepte et que
des portes s'ouvrent pour les personnes
transgenres pour qu'elles puissent
gagner leur vie de façon digne
[Musique]
il aurait plus d'un demi million de
personnes transgenres au Pakistan on les
appelle les roisaciera exclu du monde du
travail classique la majorité survit
grâce à la danse à la prostitution et à
l'amendicité
mais cette marginalisation est récente
car les rois forment l'une des
communautés les plus anciennes au monde
leur existence est mentionnée dans des
textes hindous datant du 4e siècle après
Jésus-Christ sous l'Empire Mogh elles
appartenaient même à une caste sacrée et
occupée des rôles cérémonials importants
c'est la colonisation britannique du
sous-continent indien au XVIIIe siècle
qui les a criminalisés les êtres vénérés
sont devenus hors la loi
le troisième genre est depuis mise au
banc de la société patriarcale et très
conservatrice certaines associations
leur ouvrent leurs portes comme cette
clinique intégrée à une organisation qui
soutient les transgenres on y retrouve
notre militante mais Roub qui médecin de
formation et exerce chaque semaine
je dois vérifier vos poumons
est-ce que vous pouvez prendre une
grande respiration
en fait plus de la moitié des patients
que nous voyons dans cette clinique ont
des problèmes de santé basique qui
viennent ici parce que notre système
médical actuel n'est pas inclusif pour
les trans le harcèlement des rawage à
Syrah commence dès leur entrée dans
l'hôpital cela vient du garde de la
personne à la réception de la personne
qui donne le reçu en fait il se moque
d'elle en leur demandant si elles sont
des hommes ou des femmes la plupart des
ratsacira vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté ce qui fait qu'elles n'ont pas
les moyens financiers d'accéder à des
cliniques privées et les services de
santé publique eux sont déjà surchargés
cette organisation qui a pignon sur rue
recense les personnes transgenres et
mènent des campagnes de sensibilisation
aux maladies sexuellement transmissibles
des équipes vont même sur le terrain
dans les quartiers les plus mal famés
faire passer des tests de dépistage du
sida gratuitement
la situation sécuritaire est assez
préoccupante ces derniers temps est-ce
que tu constates une détérioration sur
le terrain oui nous voyons beaucoup de
campagnes de dénigrement de la part des
moulins dans certains quartiers il n'y a
même des posters de certaines hawaja
Sira sur les murs et elles ont
l'interdiction d'y pénétrer récemment
dans un bidonville des gens m'ont arrêté
alors que j'allais faire une enquête de
recensement ils m'ont battus ils ont
déchiré mes vêtements j'ai dû me couvrir
le corps avec mon châle puis un habitant
m'a recueilli m'a donné une burqa et
appeler un taxi il m'a dit de ne plus
revenir dans le quartier parce que
c'était dangereux pour moi
ville tentaculaire cosmopolite est
réputé pour sa tolérance le climat se
détériore les violences contre les
roisaces ont explosé à travers le pays
au cours de ces dernières années
le Pakistan a même enregistré l'année
dernière le nombre de meurtres
transforme le plus élevé d'Asie 18
personnes transgenres ont été
assassinées
malgré le danger saima et minahyl
poursuivent leur campagne de dépistage
du sida dans les quartiers les plus
défavorisés ou de nombreuses rois vivent
et se prostituent
n'ayez pas de rapports sexuels sans
protection car vous ne pouvez pas savoir
si l'autre personne est porteuse une
maladie sexuellement transmissible
attention à ne pas partager vos lames de
rasoir ou vos brosses avec quelqu'un
c'est très risqué tu devrais faire un
test VIH tous les trois mois celui-ci
est négatif mais tu dois rester prudente
nous allons bientôt avoir un nouveau
stock de préservatif je te contacterai
quand nous l'aurons à bientôt au revoir
Salima travaille auprès des personnes
transgenres comme elle depuis plus de 10
ans
elle a réussi à développer des relations
de confiance
vous devez faire attention à une chose
chaque fois que quelqu'un vous fait
passer le test du VIH assurez-vous bien
qu'il utilise une aiguille neuve ne
faites jamais le test si l'aiguille est
usagé pour l'amour de Dieu je vous
demande aussi de mettre fin à cette
pratique de discrimination contre les
transgenres séropositifs les gens les
considèrent comme des personnes sales
nous pouvons vivre avec elle manger avec
elle sans courir de risques ce qui est
risqué c'est la transfusion sanguine et
les rapports sexuels non protégés plutôt
dans la journée une jeune fille
transgenre que j'ai des mortes elle
n'avait que 17 ans et elle était
séropositive j'ai beaucoup essayé de
l'aider je suis allé voir sa famille de
cœur transgenre et n'ont rien fait pour
elle puis je suis allée voir sa famille
biologique qui m'a dit qu'elle n'avait
plus rien à voir avec elle ils ont tous
profité de son argent lorsqu'elle
gagnait sa vie en travaillant dans
l'industrie du sexe mais quand elle a eu
besoin d'eux ils l'ont rejeté celles qui
sont belles ou talentueuses gagnent leur
vie en dansant mais les autres n'ont
d'autre choix que de se prostituer
normalement un client paye 200 à 300
roupies mais certains sont prêts à en
plus à condition de ne pas mettre de
préservatif c'est comme ça que le VIH
c'est beaucoup répandu dans la
communauté trans
lorsque nous essayons de les convaincre
d'utiliser des préservatifs leurs
principales réserves et que lorsqu'elles
vont se prostituer la police les arrête
toujours et les agents vérifient leur
sacs et trouvent des préservatifs les
harcènes ensuite soit il les abusent
sexuellement soit il leur explore que de
l'argent donc elle préfère ne pas
transporter de préservatif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le Pakistan bénéficier jusqu'à récemment
d’une des lois les plus progressistes au
monde pour les transgenres publiés en
2018 elle leur donnait le droit d'avoir
des papiers d'identité qui mentionnaient
leur genre non binaire une loi non
islamique selon les parties religieux
radicaux qui ont saisi la Cour fédérale
de la charia un tribunal qui s'assure
que les lois ne controviennent pas au
préceptes de l'Islam une audience a lieu
ce jour-là parmi les détracteurs du
texte l'avocat Imrane Chafik
nous sommes ici devant ce tribunal pour
contester certains articles de la Loi
sur les transgenres nous sommes venus
devant ce tribunal pour dire que la loi
sur les transgenres tel qu'elle a été
promulguée au Pakistan n'est pas
conforme au précepte du Coran et de la
Suna la loi islamique n'autorise en
aucune manière une personne a changé de
sexe au nom d'une quelconque maladie
mentale
nous n'autorisons pas les gens à changer
de sexe
Julie râne une influenceuse intersexe
est venue assister à l'audience celle
qui défendait l'étrange or il y a
quelques années a soudainement changé
d'opinion et est devenu l'une des plus
ferventes des tractrices de la loi
la loi sur le genre auto définit au
Pakistan comment devrait-elle
fonctionner concrètement dans la société
comment peut-on donner ce droit à une
personne
si je me revendique comme un oiseau
selon cette loi
allez-vous m'accepter en tant qu'oiseau
non jamais vous devrez le faire parce
que le gouvernement pakistanais dit que
vous devez l'accepter et si vous ne
m'acceptez pas en tant qu'oiseau vous me
discriminez Imrane Chafik travail depuis
plusieurs mois sur le trengend of un
texte qui comporte plusieurs articles
contraires à l'islam selon lui
les personnes transgenres sont les Syrah
ou toute personne dont l'identité ou le
genre diffère des normes sociales et
culturelles basées sur le genre assigné
au moment de leur naissance
nous sommes totalement posés à cette
disposition
vous pouvez avoir des caractéristiques
génitales incomplètes où vous n'êtes pas
un homme ou une femme à part entière
la loi islamique dit que si vous avez
des caractéristiques masculines
dominantes vous serez alors considéré
comme un homme et si vous avez des
caractéristiques féminines dominantes
vous serez alors considéré comme une
femme il n'y a donc aucune ambiguïté
en mai dernier la Cour fédérale de la
charia a finalement annulé le droit des
transgenres à se définir comme non
binaire dans leur carte d'identité un
retour en arrière pour la minorité en
attendant c'est dans les temples Sophie
à travers le pays que les rois Jasira
trouve un réconfort car ils y conservent
une place particulière mais roue se rend
régulièrement dans les édifices érigés
autour des tombeaux de personnalités
musulmanes élevées au rang de saint
s
autour de moi me regardent avec
révérence lorsque je suis dans un temple
il ne respecte certains d'entre eux
essaient de m'approcher et me demandent
de poser ma main sur la tête de leur
enfant de dire une prière pour parce que
nous les ravages à Sierra en tant que
personne du troisième genre nous sommes
considérés comme une magnifique création
du Dieu tout-puissant le Dieu
tout-puissant qui ne nous a peut-être
pas donné le pouvoir de la reproduction
mais qui nous a donné le pouvoir de la
masculinité et celui de la féminité le
terme transgenre est de plus en plus
occidentalisé médicalisée on y a mis les
notions de science et d'anatomie pure
tout le monde ici peut dire que je suis
Rawa Jasira mais personne ne s'intéresse
à ce qui se trouve entre mes jambes
parce qu'ici on respecte l'âme et pas
seulement le corps
[Musique]
encore vénéré dans les temples les rois
cielas sont de plus en plus rejetées par
le monde moderne au Pakistan un monde
qui rejette leur identité ni omnifam qui
célèbre la féminité
[Musique]